so now that we've discussed the idea
trump floated of leaving the country if
he loses to joe biden
let's get to the really authoritarian
stuff from
trump's last few rallies now i know i
know what's more authoritarian than
trump threatening to
do what many dictators have done which
is flee their country when they lose
their grip on power
but trump did something even more
dystopian at some recent rallies
over the weekend uh he again insisted
that he would lock up the bidens
remember that donald trump
vowed to lock up hillary clinton back in
2016.
lately trump has been saying obama and
biden committed the greatest political
crime in the history of the united
states
against me and yet he hasn't been able
to actually name a single law that was
broken
but it's now taken on an even uglier
tone trump is straight up saying
the bidens should be jailed take a look
i'm telling you that biden family and
others but that biden family is corrupt
it's a corrupt family
[Applause]
and with me and my kids let me tell you
my kids
i'll tell you something though i
understand you lock them up you should
lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary
this is outrageous authoritarianism this
is a nightmare and it has become
normalized
many of us don't even react anymore
trump
basking during this event in big
cnn sucks chance uh
you see many people not even wearing
masks and trump directing
the crowd's anger against the media in
the back as trump often points to
10 million dad please i had a great
father
i'm not just running against biden and
that corrupt family i'm running against
the left-wing corrupt media
and we're running against big tech
[Applause]
the authoritarianism continued all
weekend trump doing these now daily
sometimes two even three of these in a
day continued the next day in michigan
at a similar rally before we continue
with the authoritarianism a brief
interlude trump still struggling to
speak here
very powerfully struggling with the name
christopher columbus take a look
if you're italian do you happen to like
christopher or columbus
christopher okay so back to the
authoritarianism trump says lock them
all up
as his sycophants chant lock her up
about michigan governor gretchen whitmer
remember she was recently the victim
of a foiled or the the potential victim
she was the target and potential victim
of a kidnapping plot hatched up by some
q anon
trumpists and they want to lock them all
up i mean what you're doing in michigan
has been
amazing now you got to get your governor
to open up your state
okay
and get your schools open get your
schools open
the schools have to be open right
lock them all up lock them
all up that's an idea that doesn't seem
to account for due process does it and
this just continues the crowd wants
everybody locked up it's a mob
of people demanding the imprisonment of
individuals
not charged with and in some cases
not even wildly suspected of any crimes
for the second time in a single speech
trump fans chanting
lock her up about gretchen whitmer
that's right she's doing it for
everybody is locked down except my
husband he can go sailing anytime
a guy like biden and the democrats want
to keep michigan locked up
locked down and closed for business no
it's so badly hurting your state
it is reminiscent of mussolini just
mango colored that's the difference it's
tangerine colored
that's the difference between mussolini
and the stuff that we are seeing
right here uh and and trump uh uh of
course
responding to chance of lock her up uh
by saying are we having a good time this
was about hillary clinton
you know they want to erase the name of
clinton yeah hey that'll be next that's
a good one
crooked hillary will take her name does
she ever name it
i don't know if she's got her name on
anything right
if she does i'm all for it take it down
crooked
[Applause]
are we having a good time so um
yeah that's very very ugly and
aggressive stuff that is just normal at
these trump rallies
trump then again with this stuff about
maybe we'll be here four more years
maybe we go an extra four and i'm going
to make a point here that is more about
trump's fans than what trump says
himself
we'll be here for four years and then if
we decide to go for an extra four or
eight or something
[Applause]
well i think 12 is going to be now the
gold standard that'll be
that'll be hey that'll be the new chat
so
people like to argue like when trump
talks about eight more years 12 more
years
is trump kidding is he just trying to
trigger the left
that's not the primary issue to me trump
is just one guy
the real issue to me is that the crowd
cheers for it trump joking about
trying to seize power beyond what is
constitutionally allowed
and to be you know get a third term a
fourth term whatever
okay it's wacky maybe it's a joke maybe
it's not
the fact that the crowd cheers is the
nightmare
uh if you like this stuff you are
unauthoritarian whether trump means it
seriously
or not and that's where i believe our
focus on this should remain
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman